>> Sean: FORMER VOLLEYBALLS --
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IS
REFLECTING ON HIS TIME IN THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
EARLIER TONIGHT, I SAT DOWN WITH
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT TO
TALK ABOUT THIS AND MUCH MORE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JOINING US NOW IS VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
"SO HELP ME GOD".
IT'S AT amazon.com, HANNITY.COM.
BOOK STORES EVERYWHERE.
WHAT AN AMAZING LIVE YOU'VE HAD.
EVERY INTERVIEW YOU GIVEN,
EVERYBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
ONE TOPIC.
AND THERE ARE 52 CHAPTERS IN THE
BOOK.
MAYBE TWO OR THREE OF THE
CHAPTERS DEAL WITH WHAT SEEMS
THE MEDIA ONLY WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT.
THERE'S MORE TO YOU AND TO THIS
BOOK.
IT'S A DISSERVICE NOT TO GO OVER
IT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS LIFE.
HERE YOU ARE.
YOU'VE BEEN THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> SEAN, FIRST, THANKS.
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
VERY HUMBLE
ING FOR
CHANCE TO WRITE MY LIFE STORY.
GROWING UP, THE GRANDSON OF AN
IRISH IMMIGRANT.
MY FATHER A COMBAT VETERAN.
A BIG IRISH CATHOLIC FAMILY.
DREAMED OF REPRESENTING MY
HOMETOWN IN WASHINGTON D.C. TO
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO BE
CONGRESSMAN, THE GOVERNOR OF MY
HOME STATE AND SERVE AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S A TESTAMENTABLE TO GOD'S
FAITHFULNESS IN MY LIFE, THE
DECISION I MADE TO PUT MY LIFE
IN JESUS CHRIST.
MY FAMILY SUPPORTED ME EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY AND ALSO TO THE
TESTAMENT OF THE VITALITY OF OUR
IDEAS.
THAT WHETHER IT WAS MY YEARS IN
CONGRESS WHERE I WAS FIGHTING
FOR CONSERVATIVE VALUES OR
STANDING AS A CONSERVATIVE
GOVERNOR, CUTTING TAXES AND
GROWING THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND
STANDING FOR LIBERTY OR WHETHER
IT WAS THAT REMARKABLE FOUR
YEARS OF THE TRUMP PENCE
ADMINISTRATION WHERE WE TOOK
THOSE CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPALS
THAT YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
ALL OF OUR LIVES AND PUT THEM IN
TO PRACTICE.
AND WE LEFT AMERICA STRONGER AND
MORE PROSPEROUS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE REVIVED OUR ECONOMY AND
REBUILT OUR MILITARY AND TODAY
UP TO OUR ENEMIES.
WE HAD THREE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
WE GAVE AMERICA A NEW BEGINNING
FOR LIFE.
WRITE ABOUT THAT AND WRITING ALL
THE WAY TO THE END, THE
DIFFICULT DAYS AT THE END.
OUR ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T END
WELL.
WRITING ABOUT THOSE FOUR YEARS
IS WHAT SO HELPED ME GOD IS ALL
ABOUT.
MY HEART'S DESIRE IS IT GIST
PEOPLE HOPE AND ENCOURAGEMENT
THAT WHAT WE DID BEFORE WE CAN
DO AGAIN.
>> Sean: I ALWAYS SAY
CONSERVATIVE WORKS.
LIBERTY, FREEDOM, CAPITALISM,
OUR CONSTITUTION, LOWER TAXES
AND LESS GOVERNMENT.
IN THE CASE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, SECURITY
BORDERS.
IN THE CASE OF ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE HADN'T ACHIEVED THAT.
FREE AND FAIR TRADE, PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH.
CONSTITUTIONALISTS ON THE BENCH,
LAW AND ORDER AND HOW ABOUT A
CLASSICAL EDUCATION?
WE COVERED MOST OF CONSERVATISM.
>> YOU DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ABOUT THE SAME TIME.
I LIKED TO SAY YOU TAKE THREE
STEPS BACK AND AMERICA HAPPENS.
THE LAST TWO YEARS AS'S BEEN
TRAVELING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
PEOPLE HAVE COME UP TO ME FROM
TIME TO TIME AND SAID, YOU KNOW,
SEEING THE WAY THINGS HAVE GONE
DOWN HERE AT HOME, SEEMS LIKE WE
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
INTENT ON WEAKENING AMERICA AT
HOME AND ABROAD.
PEOPLE SAY YOU THINK WE CAN GET
IT BACK?
I ALWAYS SAY WE'LL GET IT ALL
BACK.
YOU'LL BE SURPRISED HOW QUICKLY
IT COMES BACK.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
PROVED PARTICULARLY IN THOSE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
TRUMP-PENCE ADMINISTRATION IS
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT KNOW WHAT'S MAKES AMERICA
PROSPEROUS STRONG AND SECURE AND
PARTNERS AND MAJORITIES IN THE
HOUSE AND IN THE SENATE, IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY WHAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH.
IT TAKE LEADERSHIP.
WITH THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP IN
WASHINGTON D.C., WE'LL BRING IT
BACK AND THEN SOME.
>> Sean: YOUR REACTION TO THE
ELECTION, REPUBLICANS HAVE THE
HOUSE.
I THINK IT'S A BIG, BIG DEAL.
AND I WAS NOT ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE OUT THERE SAYING THIS IS
GOING TO BE A RED WAVE.
I LOOKED AT THE SENATE RACES.
THEY ARE ALL BELLWETHER STATES.
THEY'RE ALL SWING STATES.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE HARD.
I CAN GIVE YOU MY REASONS WHY I
THINK THINGS HAPPENED HERE OR
THERE.
THE REALITY IS, WE -- THE
REPUBLICANS WINNING THE HOUSE,
ALBEIT A SMALL MAJORITY IS A BIG
DEAL.
THE LAST ELECTION, NOBODY
THOUGHT REPUBLICANS WOULD PICK
UP THE SEATS THAN WE DID.
>> IT WAS A TOUGHER YEAR.
THE TRUTH IS --
>> Sean: I DID SAY THE
FOUNDATIONS WERE THERE.
>> THE TRUTH IS, WE WERE
FIGHTING ON THEIR TERRAIN.
MORE THAN WE WERE IN 2010 WHEN I
WAS IN THE HOUSE MAJORITY.
WE WON 63 SEATS.
I KNEW THAT THE POSSIBILITY OF
WINNING 20 OR 30 SEATS WAS
THERE.
IT WAS A CHALLENGE.
IT WAS GOING TO BE TOUGH.
ALL THAT BEING SAID, A WIN IS A
WIN.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I WAS THERE
THE LAST TIME THAT WE FIRED
NANCY PELOSI.
I COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF
KEVIN McCARTHY AND STEVE SCALISE
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE RANK
AND FILE MEMBERS THAT WORKED
THEIR HEARTS OUT.
I TRAVELED TO 35 STATES.
I CAMPAIGNED WITH A LOT OF HOUSE
MEMBERS ACROSS AMERICA.
I WANT TO TELL YOU, THIS
INCOMING CLASS OF FRESHMEN IS
GOING TO MAKE EVERYBODY PROUD.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY GROUP OF
MEN AND WOMEN, STRONG
CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPALS.
THE DAY THAT NANCY PELOSI HANDS
THAT GAVEL TO SPEAKER KEVIN
McCARTHY IS A GREAT DAY FOR
AMERICA.
IF YOU REMEMBER, WHEN WE DID
BEFORE, WE WON THE HOUSE IN
2010.
IT WOULD BE A FEW MORE YEARS
BEFORE WE WON THE SENATE.
A COUPLE YEARS AFTER THAT, WE
WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS STEP ONE AND IT AN
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT STEP TO
STOP WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO DO
TO PILE MORE SPENDING ON THIS --
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
I DO BELIEVE WHETHER IT'S THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER,
WHETHER IT BE THIS GUSHER OF
SPENDING THAT IS DRIVING THE
WORST INFLATION IN 40 YEARS,
REPUBLICANS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
IN A POSITION WITH THE POWER OF
THE PURSE TO DRIVE FORWARD
POLICY CHANGES AND DEMAND POLICY
CHANGES THAT WILL AT LEAST BEGIN
TO MOVE OUR COUNTRY BACK TO
PROSPERITY AND SECURITY.
>> Sean: HAVE CHAIRMANSHIPS, THE
POWER OF THE PURSE, AND ALSO
HAVE THE POWER TO SUBPOENA.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAVE GONE UNINVESTIGATED.
SHOULD THAT BE THEIR TOP
PRIORITY?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD PREFER TO SEE GAS PRICES
GO LOWER AND OUR BOARDERS GET
SECURITY AND PREFER ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
JOE BIDEN ANSWERED THE QUESTION
LAST WEEK, WHAT WILL YOU DO
DIFFERENTLY?
HE'S WORD, NOTHING.
>> NOT A THING.
OVERSIGHT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT.
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
HOUSE REPUBLICANS, THE RIGHT
COMMITTEES WILL BE CREATING THAT
KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M WITH YOU.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IN THESE
NEXT TWO YEARS THAT HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, IF ONLY PASSING IT
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
PRODUCE ESSENTIALLY A PORTFOLIO
OF BILLS THAT SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE WAY BACK.
EVEN IF THEY JUST PILE UP ON
CHUCK SCHUMER'S DESK THAT WE --
HOW DO WE GET THE ECONOMY TURNED
AROUND, HOW DO WE TURN OFF THE
SPIGOT OF SPENDING THAT IS
DRIVING INFLATION.
HOW DO WE ACHIEVE ENERGY ENDS AS
WE DID UNDER THE TRUMP PENCE
ADMINISTRATION.
HOW DO WE SECURE OR BORDER.
I'D LOVE THAT BIBLE VERSE THAT
SAYS WITHOUT A VISION PEOPLE
PERISH.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE A
MAJORITY TO PASS ONE BILL AFTER
ANOTHER THAT WILL LAY OUT THAT
VISION THAT WILL REMIND PEOPLE
OF THE POLICIES THE TRUMP PENCE
ADMINISTRATION, THAT WILL
CONFRONT THE CHALLENGES FACING
OUR COUNTRY TODAY AND REALLY LAY
A PREDICATE FOR WINNING AMERICA
BACK IN 2024.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT
AMERICA'S ELECTION SYSTEM.
TO ME, WHAT IS GOING ON IN
ARIZONA, WHAT'S GOING ON IN
NEVADA, WE STILL HAVE ALL OF
THESE CALIFORNIA RACES.
50% OF THE VOTE COUNTED, 60% OF
THE VOTE COUNTED.
ALASKA, WE MIGHT NOT KNOW THE
WINNER UNTIL THANKSGIVING.
IS IT TIME FOR THE COUNTRY, IS
IT BETTER FOR THE COUNTRY -- I
WOULD PREFER IF I COULD WRITE MY
OWN ELECTION LAW THAT STATE HAS
TO DO IT CONSTITUTIONALLY BUT TO
HAVE SAME DAY VOTING, PARTISAN
OBSERVERS, WATCH THE VOTE COUNT
AND WATCH THE VOTING.
WE KNOW THE RESULTS AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
YOU HAVE GREAT BRITAIN DOES IT,
CANADA DOES IT.
ALL OF THESE COUNTRIES, PAPER
BALLOT'S.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
>> INDIANA DOES IT.
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU CAN MAKE EXCEPTIONS FOR THE
SICK, THE AFFIRMED.
THE MILITARY PEOPLE OR PEOPLE
THAT WILL BE OUT OF STATE OR OUT
OF THEIR PRECINCT THAT DAY.
I DON'T LIKE -- SEEMS LIKE
VOTING FOR MONTHS ON END,
BAIL-IN BALLOTING -- DO YOU
THINK THE SYSTEM --
>> WHEN I SAY INDIANA, WE
ACTUALLY -- WE COUNT THE VOTES
AND WE FINISH ELECTION DAY.
WE HAVE EARLY VOTING IN THE
STATE OF INDIANA.
THERE'S A LONG TRADITION OF
THAT.
WHAT IS MISSING AND IT'S A
SOURCE OF GREAT FRUSTRATION.
I'M SURE THE PEOPLE IN ARIZONA
AND CALIFORNIA.
IT'S AMAZING, SEAN, WE'RE HERE A
WEEK AFTER ELECTION DAY AND
WAITING ON THE OUTCOME OF
ELECTIONS IN CRITICAL STATES.
I JUST -- I HOLD A VIEW THAT
EARLY VOTING CAN BE MANAGED WITH
REAL INTEGRITY.
WE'VE SEEN ELECTION REFORMS
PASSED IN STATES THAT HAVE
REINFORCED PEOPLE'S CONFIDENCE
IN ELECTION INTEGRITY.
BUT ELECTION DAY OUGHT TO BE
ELECTION DAY.
WE OUGHT TO BE CALLING EVERYBODY
IN EVERY ONE OF THEIR STATES
SHOULD SAY, WE MIGHT HAVE TO
STAY UP LATE ON ELECTION DAY TO
FIND OUT THE RESULTS BUT WE CAN
COUNT THE VOTES AND TELL
PEOPLE --
>> I'M HOPING WE'RE GETTING
REACTION.
NEVER CAME IN.
>> ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR FUTURE.
POLITICALLY.
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT GETTING
BACK IN THE ARENA?
ON THE FENCE?
>> KAREN AND I ARE SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERING WHAT ROLE WE MIGHT
PLAY IN THE FUTURE.
INCLUDING AS A CANDIDATE FOR
PUBLIC OFFICE AGAIN.
>> Sean: ONLY ONE OFFICE THAT
YOU'D RUN FOR.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
FOR US, A FRIEND OF MINE SAID TO
ME, THERE'S TWO KINDS OF PEOPLE
IN POLITICS.
PEOPLE ARE CALLED ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE DRIVEN.
CANDIDLY AS I WRITE IN SO HELP
ME GOD, I'VE BEEN BOTH.
I ALLOWED MY AMBITION TO GET
AHEAD OF ME EARLY ON.
I FOUND MYSELF CAUGHT UP IN
CAMPAIGNS THAT AT THE END OF THE
DAY I WASN'T PROUD OF.
WHEN IT CAM BACK AROUND A DECADE
LATER, THE YEAR THAT I WAS
ELECTED TO CONGRESS, THE FIRST
TIME IN 2000, KAREN AND I HAD
THREE SMALL CHILDREN.
WE STEPPED FORWARD ON FAITH.
WE PUT OUR LIVES AND OUR CAREERS
IN THE LORD'S HANDS.
WE RAN CAMPAIGNS THAT WE CAN BE
PROUD OF.
WE LAID OUT OUR CONSERVATIVE
VALUES AND TRUSTED GOD FOR THE
OUTCOME.
SO WHAT WE'LL LOOK FOR IN THE
DAYS AHEAD IS WHAT OUR SENSE OF
CALLING IS AS A FAMILY.
WE HAVE TWO IN THE MILITARY IN
THE IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
BECAUSE OF DEPLOYMENTS, WE
HAVEN'T ALL BEEN TOGETHER FOR
THREE YEARS.
IN INDIANA, WE'LL HAVE THE WHOLE
FAMILY BACK TOGETHER OVER THE
HOLIDAYS.
WE'LL HEAR OUR KIDS OUT THAT
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A PART OF OUR
PUBLIC LIFE AND KAREN AND I WILL
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT WHERE WE
THINK WE MIGHT BEST SERVE.
I PROMISE TO KEEP YOU POSTED,
SEAN.
>>
>> Sean: THERE'S 52 CHAPTERS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS
INTERVIEW FIRST.
ALL OF THE OTHERS WANT TO TALK
ABOUT YOU AND DONALD TRUMP,
JANUARY 6.
NEGATE FOUR SUCCESSFUL YEARS.
I CAN GO THROUGH THE
ACHIEVEMENTS.
YOU CAN PROBABLY LIST THEM
BETTER THAN ME.
>> Jesse: YOU WERE PART OF THEM.
I WASN'T.
THE FOUR SUCCESSFUL YEARS
TOGETHER AND CULMINATED WITH AN
OVAL OFFICE MEETING, ONE-ON-ONE
WITH YOU AND THE PRESIDENT THAT
WENT ON FOR 90 MINUTES OR SO.
TO ME THAT TALKS ABOUT, OKAY, WE
DID THIS TOGETHER.
WAS THERE MUCH DISAGREEMENT
PUTTING THIS ONE ISSUE ASIDE OF
JANUARY 6, WAS THERE MUCH
DISAGREEMENT IN THE FOUR YEARS
THAT YOU RECALL?
I DON'T RECALL IT.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT AS
DIFFERENT AS THE TWO OF US ARE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I ACTUALLY
FORGED A CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP.
HE WAS MY FRIEND.
WE SPENT TIME TOGETHER EVERY DAY
WHEN WE WERE BOTH AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
SOMETIMES UP TO FOUR HOURS A
DAY.
>> Sean: YOU HAD AN OFFICE.
>> I HAD AN OFFICE IN THE WEST
WING AND FOUND MYSELF BACK AND
FORTH BACK AND FORTH ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
I CHRONICLE THAT IN THE BOOK.
WE HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL
RELATIONSHIP THAT OBVIOUSLY
DIDN'T END WELL.
I'LL ALWAYS BELIEVE I DID MY
DUTY ON THAT TRAGIC DAY UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION AND LAWS OF
THIS COUNTRY.
BUT IN THE AFTERMATH OF THOSE
DIFFICULT DAYS, THE PRESIDENT
AND I DID SIT DOWN.
WHY TALKED THROUGH IT.
I RECOUNT SOME OF THAT IN MY
BOOK.
AS I TOLD YOU, LAST FALL WHEN WE
GET TOGETHER, WE PARTED
AMICABLY.
WE SPOKE A NUMBER OF TIMES AFTER
I LEFT OFFICE.
FRANKLY WHEN THE PRESIDENT
RETURNED TO SOME OF THE RHETORIC
ABOUT ME AND OTHERS THAT HAD
TAKEN A STAND FOR THE
CONSTITUTION, I THOUGHT IT WAS
BEST THAT WE JUST GO OUR
SEPARATE WAYS.
BUT THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
ABILITY TO PART AMICABLY CAME
FROM THAT RELATIONSHIP THAT WAS
FORGED IN THOSE FOUR YEARS.
I WILL ALWAYS BE PROUD OF THE
RECORD OF THE TRUMP PENCE
ADMINISTRATION AND WHAT WE DID
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, I MEAN,
RUSSIA NEVER TRIED TO REDRAW
INTERNATIONAL LINES DURING OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WAS THE ONLY ADMINISTRATION
IN THE 21st CENTURY FOR WHICH
THAT WAS TRUE.
WE CHANGED THE NATIONAL
CONSENSUS ON CHINA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MEETS WITH
PRESIDENT XI TODAY AND PROMISES
MORE TALKS WITH CHINA.
WE DIDN'T JUST TALK.
WE IMPOSED $250 BILLION IN
TARIFFS.
WE STRENGTHENED OUR MILITARY
ALLIANCES IN THE REGION.
WE MAINTAINED FREEDOM OF
NAVIGATION.
HELD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT.
SEVEN MILLION GOOD PAYING JOBS.
WE CUT TAXES, ROLLED BACK
REGULATIONS.
UNLEASHED AMERICAN ENERGY,
ACHIEVED AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
APPOINTED CONSERVATIVES TO OUR
COURTS AND REDUCED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION BY 90%.
I CHRONICLE HOW WE DID ALL OF
THOSE THINGS.
WE DIDN'T GET EVERYTHING DONE
THAT WE WANTED TO GET DONE.
I WRITE IN THAT FIRST YEAR ABOUT
COMING UP ONE VOTE SHORT OF
REPEALING AND REPLACING
OBAMACARE TO SEE THE WAY -- WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S LEADERSHIP, WE
RALLIED BACK AND CUT TAXES AND
RESTORED THE STRENGTH AND
VITALITY OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: I'M NOT ASSIGNING
BLAME, BUT JOHN McCAIN WAS THE
ONE VOTE IN THAT MOMENT.
>> HE WAS.
IT WAS -- I TRIED TO CAPTURE
THAT MOMENT.
>> Sean: PEOPLE WILL READ THE
BOOK.
YOU DID MULTIPLE INTERVIEWS TO
TALK ABOUT THAT TIME, THAT
PERIOD.
I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR ALL OF THESE
YEARS.
GOING BACK TO THE TIME THAT YOU
WERE A CONGRESSMAN AND A
GOVERNOR AND THIS WHOLE OTHER
LIFE AND THIS WHOLE BOOK THAT
YOU WRITE.
PEOPLE WANT TO FOCUS ON THE ONE
CHAPTER.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE TIME DID
YOU HAVE HARMONY IN THIS
RELATIONSHIP?
I KNOW YOU BOTH.
I'VE KNOWN YOUR BOTH FOR 30
YEARS.
I COULDN'T DEFINE TWO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
VERY DIFFERENT.
RIGHT?
AND BUT YET, WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE TIME WAS IT A PERFECT
PARTNERSHIP IN TERMS OF GETTING
THE JOB DONE?
>> YOU KNOW, I RECOUNT A FEW
MOMENTS WHERE WE HAD
DISAGREEMENTS.
BUT I ALWAYS KEPT THOSE IN
PRIVATE.
YOU KNOW, I TRULY DO BELIEVE IN
HUMILITY AND ORIENTATION TO
AUTHORITY.
AS VICE PRESIDENT I BELIEVE MY
ROLE WAS TO BE THERE TO SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT.
NOT TO BE JUST ONE MORE VOICE
AMONG A CHORUS OF PEOPLE WITH
OPINIONS.
I THINK THAT CREATED A RAPPORT
BETWEEN OF US TRUST.
GENUINE FRIENDSHIP.
IT'S PART OF WHAT MADE -- WHAT
HAPPENED AT THE END SO
DIFFICULT.
I KNEW WHAT MY DUTY WAS UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I MADE THAT CLEAR MANY TIMES
OVER TO THE PRESIDENT.
HE MADE LEGAL ADVISERS AROUND
HIM THAT WERE TELLING HIM
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE ENDED UP HAVING TO HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT, VERY LOUD
DISAGREEMENT IN PUBLIC.
WHAT MADE THAT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT IS BECAUSE LITERALLY
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY FROM THE
DAY I WAS ADDED TO THE NATIONAL
TICKET ALL THE WAY UNTIL
ELECTION DAY 2020, WE HAD A
STRONG, CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT WAS BUILT ON
MUTUAL RESPECT.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I'LL
ALWAYS BE PROUD OF THE RECORD OF
THE TRUMP PENCE ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: WE CANNOT POSSIBLY
CAPTURE THE BACK BUT IT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE INSIDERS VIEW WHAT
IT WAS LIKE FOUR VERY HISTORIC